this isn't really a sport it's just a uh
just a game what are you talking about
it's it's like in the olympics and stuff
it's
called how comfortable these clothes are
look at this
you're not supposed to be able to do
this with pants on like these pants are
so comfortable
i keep having to look down to make sure
my dick isn't up it doesn't even feel
like you're wearing clothes right now
do you know why that is it's just
because so many unathletic fat [ __ ]
play this game
dude the fact that everybody has to shut
up when you hit the ball
there's nobody guarding you and every oh
simmer down
simmer down everybody he's going to hit
the ball
talking to a seahawk fan here now is it
true the rumor is that you guys
aren't as loud as they say that they
actually designed the stadium
to contain it
sounds like a pigeon you ever watched
somebody take a free throw on basketball
uh yeah there's like 5 000 people going
[ __ ] you [ __ ] your mother and this thing
here it's not even moving
dude they've changed the clubs these
used to be made out of wood it was too
heavy for them
too heavy for these cheating banker
[ __ ] right of course there we go
so all you do is you just you don't look
there you just go like this
and you go like that look at that jesus
christ
that's how you play golf it's cause you
were talking
sorry all right another thing that i'm
loving
about this stadium is they don't care
about color coordination
whatever bucket of paint is on sale
they're going for it this beautiful
uplifting brown that they have painted
this uh isn't your idol richard pryor
everybody all right let's pray oh no you
don't either richard pryor
come on good to see you like asking a
guitar player if he likes hendrix i mean
he's the man all right this is the man
see how i do that you just ask me a
question all of a sudden i make it
uncomfortable
i make sure you're speaking to the mic
there you go
um we discovered that there's a weirdest
story anybody's ever said
that like made me uncomfortable from the
beginning
no it's the serial killer like tone
of his his complete lack of emotion
thank you
can i tell you something this happened
yes yeah
you know what and i know bill i think
missing from that story is the sound of
somebody gagged screaming in the other
room
right now i know that you [ __ ] go
yeah and i know that you suspect that my
husband is a psycho i've heard i've
heard about
he is yeah no i know and i've i actually
agree yeah
and i've been trying to prove this on
this show it's just like you know
there's like bud in this bud light
there's like psycho and psycho light
like he just
he's not the uh the high calorie one
that can't get married and have kids
that's right
yes but if you if his thoughts were a
movie yep
yeah definitely nc 17. yep he's a
functioning psychopath
bill burns ladies and gentlemen we're
getting into the mind of bill bell
late for his own podcast bill are you
ready for this
this is the best part that i think this
is this is what's mind-blowing that
people are going to love
build bro your own name on your [ __ ]
sweatshirt
well outside of that i mean brandon kept
we know who you are
just in case you didn't bill i wore a
shirt to remind you what's the big
[ __ ] deal man
all right it's just honey with kevin
hart i hand out hoodies to homeless
people because i
care about downtown l.a go see jumanji
part
19. the studio system has ruined you
you want me to be a soft uh you know you
know one of those twitter
tough guys when guys come and sit on the
couch i go right after him don't you
respect me for that
no i don't your big dumb desk hiding
behind your microphone thank you for
keeping it real college
yeah i kept it 100 but when you kill
somebody out and then have them in front
of you
that's punk no but then you can actually
just admit that you're wrong
when the guy's delivering because now
he's delivering he's still trying oh
yeah he's not admitting that he's wrong
that's what i'm saying there you are
look at billy how are you you look like
a [ __ ] prize
i stupid headphones to work here
something that'll work let me see if
these ones will work hold on a second no
they work good
my headphones aren't working for me
though oh okay
it's about me nick it's not about you
here here we go
are you from southie no that's a good
will hunting question that i've answered
for 15 years ever since that movie came
out
are you good at math do you like apples
where are you from in boston i lived in
a
a safe suburbs sagas do you really like
i would like to know how beautiful you
are look how beautiful you know how many
psychos are out there i'm not gonna tell
where i live
what's your social security number you
don't have any kids
no i don't i don't like the way you said
that
you don't have any kids no i don't have
any kids i'm going to adopt
i'm going to rescue a couple of the
children that work till 4 in the morning
to put this they make them catch it when
it rains
okay and you have to stand out there
until it's full and if it doesn't rain
that day you actually get beaten
and they dock your pay because you
didn't do the rain dance right and then
we sit here
and we drink this [ __ ] and we wonder why
china hates us
i don't have i don't have any sympathy
for fat people by the way that's another
one
no i don't know does that where are they
on kick a ginger date
huh they send me a card they don't
people only care about
their group that's it i've noticed that
they're doing stand-up
the people when you when you make fun of
animals the people who get offended
is is the animal people right you make
you make fun of asians the asians come
up you make fun of this right but the
asian people
never never defend the fatties right the
fat people never go hey lay off those
chihuahua jokes
they don't it's just it's very
selfish where they'll sit there and just
subject after
subject is going by and they're all
laughing
and the second it comes to their
neighborhood it's it's not jokes anymore
the these these statements that you made
like i must meet the press
i'm a realist though yeah conspiracy
theory has gotten a bad name where now
it's it's it's
become synonymous with like moronic
thought like if you're into conspiracy
theory if you think like the bankers
need to be stopped then you also think
the moon is made out of cheese
and you think that there's shape-shift
shifters and like lizard people
you know they just try to knock it down
it's like this country started
with a conspiracy that's how it came we
won
so they're considered heroes and rebels
you know whatever
revolutionaries but if they lost they
would be hanged for conspire
for conspiring yeah it's not like it
spontaneously happened
yeah like all of a sudden everybody just
picked up a gun and started shooting at
the british
you know they sat around they said they
planned it out i'm kind of getting tired
of these people
it's funny when you said we when i'm
like did we really win but i don't know
what you're saying i understand what
you're saying
now is that that african-american thing
yeah
you know i was reading a little bit
about you and it says that you have a
tendency to kind of go with your first
thought
yeah because reading makes you sleepy
that's right
my first thought is this is the best
week to be here the week before the
super bowl
that is so true before all the [ __ ]
fly in uh-huh you know
yeah they just want to get out wow i
want to get out of here before that
but it's true this is like the oscars
for prostitutes
okay all right entire week let's
remember we're too rated here
folks um yeah he he like he's like a 300
pound dude and he's
bullying another 300-pound dude oh i did
hear about that
now you know what it is about that whole
thing i don't think it's any of my
business
you know what i mean that was a private
phone call
you know and then you put it on tv dude
if you took
90 of my my text messages and phone
messages and you put them on the news
you would run out of podiums to put in
front of me
that i would have to apologize to crap
me and derosa say to each other forget
it
my stuff is so bad you actually have
code
you know what's crazy is i knew that
yeah i'm closing up with joe where he's
like look at the fake name
yeah look at everybody here
getting silent like you don't do the
same thing
you know i do know
everybody has yeah you got your little
paula deen moments you got something
you know everybody coming down on that
chef like they're a perfect person
[Music]
i'm a huge fan of hockey i love it and i
love that people don't get it
down in the states i love it i love them
why do they make why do they let them
fight i can't see the puck it's like
music to my ears
it's like good yeah get out of here just
get out of here let me let me let me
watch it
do you remember when they lit up the
puck for a few years on tv oh
yeah that was you guys you know no but
yeah but the nhl
well no no wait are you wait a minute
wait a minute time out
time out time out the nhl is you guys
too
so all the owners had to agree with that
and you all had to be like we gotta we
gotta like expand this thing
we thought we'd funnel money into canada
and keep it here but you guys took it
over
like you tend to do but well i'm not
gonna apologize
no i don't know you're big on the yeah
that's just business dude you're acting
like we came and knocked you on the head
you know what we're about
yeah we wait wait a minute oh yeah wait
a second
fellow white person not native to this
country how did you guys get this up
here did the native americans go oh
will we like these white guys you can
have all that land
jesus christ no ah i get it your [ __ ]
smells like maple syrup up here do you
know what you're telling me
all right i'll go with it so your
christian background is is part of the
the show yes and i wanted to talk to you
about jesus after that well
i'm not the only reason why i bring it
up but some people thought maybe you
went a little too far
you know as far as what well they
thought that maybe you were being
disrespectful to the christian religion
i'm telling you you need to google oh
good lord so did you
feel you were disrespectful or just you
you were just having fun with some of
the crucifixes and
stuff like that i don't even know what
yeah i mean we did maybe two jokes about
that
yeah exactly don't you think the
catholic church went a little too far
more so than my cartoon i listened to a
couple of jokes i know this is a morning
show you can't bring up all those crimes
you know what
they just they just sort of kept moving
them around you know like those killer
whales at sea world after it kills a
trainer they'll then move it up to
seattle they don't give them their
background
all right i'm not totally following but
i don't
know what i'm talking about it's a
morning show i understand
anytime that kid would miss the
graduation and then
it was a feel-good story and we want to
leave if you want to feel good about
america you watch the morning shows you
don't watch us you know
and one joking if that kid's story about
the graduation was late night that would
have been a whole different story
what do you think he's still missing we
can't find him all we found was his hat
but you watch in the morning it's great
it all worked out he got his own
personal graduation
like i was in such a great mood look how
yellow this couch
is it's like the sun listen where's the
line you know i don't think there is a
line i mean it's an
art form i would just there you go one
person agreed
i just pharmaceutical companies can hand
out [ __ ] opiates to everybody like
they're handing out flyers to some
shitty jam band
and get everybody hooked on heroin and
nobody has a problem with it
but you tell a caitlyn jenner joke in a
[ __ ] strip mall and all of a sudden
people get offended that's a good point
makes a good point